hey david people often talk about if x
wins i'm moving to canada what would it
really take for you to leave the united
states
this is a good question i mean remember
so i was born in argentina moved to the
us when i was five
anytime i want to i could move back to
argentina
um the economy is a disaster in
argentina
a lot of the it's not exactly a place i
would love to be
from the standpoint of the virus
although things aren't great in the
united states
in massachusetts things are pretty good
and massachusetts can continue to be
you know a good place to live in general
theoretically
i could move to israel and
after a year i believe i would become
eligible for citizenship so
if the question is of the places i could
realistically go
and and move to permanently what would
it take i mean things would have to get
pretty
pretty bad here in the united states and
particularly in massachusetts things
have to get worse
we do have a country of 50 states and
the situation living in massachusetts
is very different than living in
mississippi from the standpoint of
health education
climate business regulation social
issues it's it's completely different
if things got really bad in
massachusetts or i believe that they
were going to
i would look at a sort of sabbatical of
sorts
not from work i would just work
elsewhere and depending on the
coronavirus situation
argentina could be a possibility and
israel could be a possibility right now
i don't see either of them as
places i would move to in the immediate
what would it take for me to permanently
abandon the united states
i don't know i mean you know my parents
live here um
my girlfriend's family is in the united
states
uh i have most of my relatives are in
argentina
some in france some in israel some in
you know different places
my social life is in the united states i
have a us-based business which i could
run from another country but it's
certainly easier being here it would
really take a lot and this is why
when we hear oh billionaires will
abandon the country if taxes go
up maybe a couple of them will but by
and large
people live where they live for reasons
and the longer they live there the more
attached they are
to it and it would really take a lot for
me to say i'm just leaving the united
states
permanently it doesn't seem something
that i would be likely to do now that
being said i have said
if things were to get very bad in
massachusetts in the fall
with the virus would i look to see
can i without breaking any rules can i
go
somewhere that's doing well quarantine
for 14 days take a negative test and
sort of just do the show elsewhere for
four months or five months until things
settle down could it be uh you know some
picturesque part of
rural northern france or something i
mean that sounds amazing
uh that is a different story but in
terms of truly just abandoning the
united states
it's not likely and i think we have to
be really careful to
take too seriously any time someone says
if x wins if x loses i'm leaving the
country particularly by the way
when a lot of the people that say that
often say they would move to countries
that represent what it is they are
trying to avoid
you'll hear republicans say if trump
wins i'm leaving the country and going
to x y or z
uh a lot of those countries if trump
loses rather
or if obama wins we heard it i'm moving
to ex-country
most of those countries are more in the
direction of obama than what some of
these people want
really counter-intuitive and for the
most part these are empty threats
that we shouldn't pay too much attention
to we've got a great
bonus show for you today get instant
access by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com
we will see you then or otherwise on
monday
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video